- [Narrator] Have you ever
gotten up in a good mood,
put on your absolute favorite outfit,
went outside to have a fun day in the sun,
and then ended up soaking wet,
caught in a sudden rainstorm?
Yeah, same.
Unfortunately, we can't
control the weather.
Weather changes from day to day
and from place to place,
so scientists have to consider
a lot of different factors
to understand it.
Weather can refer to humidity,
or amount of water vapor in the air,
temperature,
air pressure,
wind,
and, of course, precipitation
like rain or snow.
When heat from the sun enters
Earth's lower atmosphere,
it affects the temperature
and humidity of the air.
As this National Aeronautics
and Space Administration map shows,
air masses with certain characteristics
tend to form in similar places.
There's many ways to
classify these air masses,
but to keep it simple,
these blue blobs represent
colder air masses,
which tend to be closer to the poles,
and the red blobs
represent warm air masses,
which are often found near the equator,
where the sun's energy is strongest.
The qualities of an air mass
may also depend on where it forms.
Air masses that form over land
tend to have less humidity
than those that form over an ocean.
Air masses can even change
characteristics as they move.
For example, when a very
cold and dry air mass
moves over the ocean,
it will likely pick up
warmth and moisture,
transforming it into a slightly warmer
and more humid air mass.
Weather results from these air masses
moving from areas with high air pressure
to areas with low air pressure.
When this happens,
a high- or low-pressure system can form.
A high-pressure system has
higher pressure at its center
than the areas around it,
so air moves out from the center.
High-pressure systems
typically bring clear skies.
A low-pressure system has
lower pressure at its center
than the areas around it,
so air is sucked into
the center of the system.
Low-pressure systems typically
bring more intense weather.
Why is this?
Well, low-pressure systems
are often associated
with what we call fronts.
A front is a boundary that forms
when air masses of different
temperatures collide
near Earth's surface.
Different types of fronts can then form
depending on how those air masses meet.
A warm front occurs
when a warm air mass moves in
to a replace a cold air mass.
Since warm air is less
dense than cold air,
it rises above the colder air,
causing a lot of overcast
skies, moderate rain or snow,
and warm temperatures.
A cold front occurs when
a cold air mass moves in
to replace a warm air mass.
The dense cold air pushes
the warmer air mass upward,
causing larger clouds to build overhead
and bringing heavy rain or thunderstorms,
strong winds, and cool
temperatures with them.
Weather is so complex
that it can be difficult to
predict what will happen next.
Luckily, scientists have
developed technologies
that help model weather patterns
so we can all make more informed choices
about what to expect when we go outside.
To do that, they set up tools
like satellites and Doppler radar
to observe atmospheric conditions
such as wind speed,
temperature, air pressure,
and nearby geographic features.
They can input the data they
record into computer models,
which can use that information
to predict future weather.
Have you ever seen a map like this
used in a weather forecast?
This National Oceanic and
Atmospheric Administration map
uses data from a Doppler radar station
that measured the
progression of a severe storm
over the Northeastern United States.
The most intense central
parts of the storm
are shown in red,
with colors down the rainbow
representing progressively less
intense parts of the storm.
As technology has advanced,
these weather reports
have gotten more accurate,
but with so many factors to consider
weather is still only
somewhat predictable.
That's why you'll always hear
probabilistic weather predictions,
providing a percentage
that refers to how confident the model is
that the prediction will happen.
If your local weather forecast
says there's a 30% chance of rain,
it's less likely, but still possible
that you're going to get rain.
If it says there's a 90%
chance of snow on another day,
you're most likely going to get snow.
Even if weather
predictions aren't perfect,
it's amazing that scientists
figured out how to understand
such a complicated phenomenon.
Without modern tools and models,
it would be much more
difficult for us to plan ahead
and be prepared for
possible weather hazards.
Next time you have a
fancy day out planned,
be sure to check the weather
forecast before you go.
If it says there's a
decent chance of rain,
don't forget your umbrella.